so I was born and raised in San Diego
but I have been in Denver for the last
ten years up until this year I was
raised me and my four older brothers I'm
the youngest and the only girl and my
father raised me my mom left me when I
was but I saved about three years old
she left me when I was about five and
till I was about
um even she came back yeah and she was
actually
Deena homeless dangerous and yeah you
know she's never apologized to me about
it when I asked her about it you know
she blames my dad I'm saying you know
he's the one that got her started on
drugs in the first place
and I tell her well you know he quit
because he had you know five kids to
raise four of us aren't even his he's
actually my one of my brothers father
that's it
you know I said excuse me I'm gonna just
sit there I said you know he quit
because he had five kids to raise you
know what
you know and should never apologize
crystal and I've been doing crystal
since I was fifteen and twenty eight
thirteen years and I've been doing
heroin for seven years eight years now
since I was 20 oh yeah I work I work in
here I never worked until I came around
here up until I came out here in the
other January beginning of February I
had only been with seven guys my whole
life I was a lot more now uh-huh you
know but I am always careful and safe
yeah I mean you never know every every
time you get a new taking a risk you
know but I have an addiction you know
and
and you know with heroin I'm sure I
don't know you know it's not just a lot
you know it's a physical dependency on
it you know like I quit last year for
like eight nine months from March all
the way to December so I came out here
it's supposed to be for ten days I came
out here with the truck driver and like
I said I'd never worked before I came
out here by my home in Denver and he
offered me $10,000 to take a trip with
him for ten days just to keep him
company literally like you know the most
I had done with him like was rough his
arm and I already had $3,000 like so
that was just from hanging out with him
a day in Denver so when he offered me
$10,000 for just my company ten-day trip
here and back he's like I said he's a
truck driver I said okay sure you know
like I don't generally do things like
that but for whatever reason like I felt
comfortable enough with him to do it I
didn't know you smoked crack and I don't
judge nobody you know everybody I do you
know what I do you know I don't judge
nobody but if I had known it might have
you know I've I said I wouldn't have
come out here but I might have even had
a little bit more precautions you know
so we came out here and I guess I don't
know if he had been using he was just
hiding it or what but maybe he had a
relapse when he came to skid row
whatever so he
we ended up getting in an argument in
town i'll now that I know the area it's
like it's funny so we got an argument
down on like 14th and Matteo oh so this
was after we had been in here for like
maybe three days already and he was
coming down here to buy crack every day
so it almost fine no issues and so then
we were sitting on like 14th and Matteo
and we had been sitting there for like
three hours and he turned and he told me
why have we been sitting here for three
hours and I said because you just want
one more hit one more head one more head
and he was driving it was his car like I
don't even know why he so we drove truck
out here and then he bought a Hummer
when he got out here for like forty
thousand dollars he paid cash we're
driving the Hummer he we've been sitting
there for three hours he asked me why
have we been sitting here for three
hours
and I said cuz you just want one more
hit one more he said it's my car like
I'll do it the [ __ ] I want
we'll do it and I said okay well let me
out and he had the child locks up I said
let me out I just want to pull out I
just want some fresh air whatever so I
got a car I slammed the door like I was
mad oh I told him like I said do you
ain't nothing but a crackhead with a
little bit of money and I got a hold of
the car and slammed the door and then he
took off I didn't accuse him to take off
like and then he didn't answer the phone
for six hours I mean he
did he said I'm already on my way back
to Denver and that's how I got here
uh-huh that was back in so we left
Denver like the last month of January
but like the beginning February first I
think it's when I got here even back
home I was a functioning drug I was a
general manager for six years you know I
have two kids you know this is not me at
all you know so yeah back home with her
their dad's I had two kids two different
dads
okay so my older son is with his father
he's eight his dad is very well I got
with him when I was 18 but he is a nurse
he owns his house he's got three cars of
tomorrow a truck
he does well for himself you know and so
he has my son
I still have 50/50 custody of him and
I've asked him like why haven't you
taken me back to court and he's
because I know this isn't goofy I know
this is just a face and you know get
over it
soon hopefully for Jaden you know yeah
so he's with his dad and then my younger
son is with my ex-mother-in-law
his grandma because my baby dad so last
year when I quit using so me my baby my
second baby dad we were together for six
years and he's the one that actually got
me started on so when I could last year
and he didn't want to quit I left him
because I had all I had always been the
breadwinner and I said as a general
manager for six years and so you know
when he didn't want to work or support
his habit or do anything I said I'm not
gonna work and hustle and it's that just
to support your habit look I'm not even
getting high anymore you know just like
your last thing and so we split up and
he ended up becoming homeless in Denver
and it's still homeless in Denver and my
son is with his mother who is actually
in the process of filing for temporary
custody of my son
obviously you know to get back home but
you know this place is very you know you
get stuck so yeah like I miss my kids
you know but I don't know like if this
is guilty like that if this is like
terrible for me to say you know but like
I'm not enjoying myself but like I am I
guess you don't like I never did any of
this you know I got pregnant at 18 and
you know I had both my kids every day
since the day they report and so yeah
I'm just I never experienced any of this
you know I never got a debate system you
know so yeah my eight-year-old I talked
to him I video chat with him and you
know he asked me just the other day
actually he said where are your mom I
said I'm still in LA what are you doing
there anyways she told me you know like
oh nothing you know like it's uh you
know I know that they're both good right
now you know they're both safe they're
both
I was never uh a bad mom like I was a
really good mom I actually tell people
you know like the thing that I feel like
sucks right now is I feel like my kids
are missing out on like a really cool
mom you know like yeah I feel like
they're good right now you know and like
I said it was never a bad mom but I
definitely feel like I need to feel a
lot better mentally and and healthy you
know before I go back home I guess
that's you know my plan is to to work on
me and I don't know you know figure out
who I am